>> Bill: WE’VE BEEN WAITING FOR
THIS.
MIGRANT ENCOUNTERS AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER DURING THE
MONTH OF DECEMBER.
IT SHOWS THE NUMBER TRYING TO
ENTER THE U.S. LAST MONTH
HIGHER THAN THE THREE PREVIOUS
DECEMBERS COMBINED.
WE’RE ON THE STORY LIVE IN
BROWNSVILLE, TEXAS.
BILL, GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
RIGHT NOW WE’RE IN FRONT OF A
PARKING GARAGE IN BROWNSVILLE
WHERE FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME
DURING THIS BORDER CRISIS WE
ACTUALLY WITNESSED THE MASS
RELEASE SINGLE ADULT MALE
MIGRANTS FROM FEDERAL CUSTODY.
LOOK AT THE VIDEO WE SHOT HERE
ON SUNDAY AFTERNOON.
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT ARE
FEDERALLY CONTRACTED BUSES
DROPPING OFF DOZENS OF MIGRANTS
AT THE PARKING GARAGE.
WHAT YOU NOTICE IS THESE ARE
ALL SINGLE ADULTS BEING
RELEASED.
ALMOST ALL OF THEM MEN, NO
CHILDREN, NO FAMILY UNITS.
THE RAISED EYEBROWS WITH US.
SINGLE ADULTS ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE EXPELLED FROM THE COUNTRY IN
TITLE 42.
WE WATCHED AS THEY WERE USHERED
INSIGHT.
AFTER A SHORT TIME IN THE
OFFICE WE STARTED NOTICING TAXI
CABS SHOWING UP TO THE PARKING
GARAGE.
MIGRANTS CAME OUT OF THE
OFFICE, GOT INTO THE TAXI CABS
AND THEY STARTED DRIVING AWAY.
WE FOLLOWED THE TAXI CABS AND
WENT TO AN AIRPORT AND THOSE
MIGRANTS WERE DROPPED OFF AT
THE AIRPORT TO FLY AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
WE TALKED TO A COUPLE OF THEM
SAYING THEY WERE GOING TO
ATLANTA, HOUSTON, MIAMI AND
JUST CROSSED ILLEGALLY AND PAID
A CARTEL $2,000 TO DO SO.
WE STOPPED IN BROWNSVILLE TO
ASK WHAT’S GOING ON HERE AND
CONFIRMED THEY’RE INVOLVED.
THE STATEMENT IF THEY CAN PULL
IT UP NOW.
CITY OF BROWNSVILLE SAYING IN
REFERENCE TO MIGRANTS IN
FEDERAL CUSTODY THE CITY OF
BROWNSVILLE’S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT THROUGH
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE FROM FEMA
FACILITATES THE TRANSFER OF
THESE MIGRANTS TO THEIR FINAL
DESTINATION BY ALLOWING THEM TO
USE SERVICES TO CONTACT
FAMILIES, NGOs OR TAXI CAB.
IT IS A STAGING CENTER WHERE
MIGRANTS COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY ARE PROVIDED WITH
TRAVEL INFORMATION TO
FACILITATE TRANSFER TO FINAL
DESTINATION AND TOLD ME MEDIA
IS NOT ALLOWED TO GO INSIDE AND
SHOOT VIDEO.
I REACHED OUT TO CBP TO ASK
ABOUT THE RELEASE OF SINGLE
ADULT MIGRANTS.
THEY SAID THEY WEREN’T INVOLVED.
I REACHED OUT TO ICE AND SAID
THEY’RE LOOKING INTO IT.
HOWEVER, A SOURCE WITHIN ICE
TELLS ME THIS WAS AN ICE
RELEASE.
WE’LL SEND IT BACK TO YOU.
>> Bill: AMAZING STUFF.